99.9 of all species that have ever
existed
are now extinct so it's extinction is
the rule survival is the exception
that's an important thing to know is
that you know potentially we have come
close before
this isn't something that is completely
unprecedented
if we're worried about existential risks
annihilating our future
why spend any time studying the past
that's a good question uh so i i
i hope as we talk through this uh the
the true
uh significance of what i'm about to say
will um be elaborated further but um
i think that it's so easy to
focus on uh the risks
coming towards us coming down track um
and it's slightly harder to take stock
and look backwards and see
just how far we've come one of the
things i mean
by that is that uh the very ability for
us to even be able to see those risks
ahead
the risks on the horizon that's a
massive achievement
for humanity um
for for our knowledge of the world for
our knowledge of what
is best to do within the world um
that's a massive achievement and again i
hope that you know as we speak through
this uh
you know um the truth of this might uh
hopefully kind of uh
unfurl um but
you know some of our biggest
achievements are almost invisible to us
um some of you know uh
some of the most profound um uh
breakthroughs of human knowledge are
often invisible to us
um so you know i
often point towards the fact um
of uh take slavery for example for most
for the majority of human history
uh people presumed that it was just part
of the natural order of things
uh you know um it wasn't questioned
uh all of us these days kind of take it
for granted
that uh that's you know inherently wrong
um another example i like to use uh
is um perspective right so
you know think back to being a kid in
school um
you'd learn to draw your first cube or
your first uh
prism or you know triangle uh pyramid
sorry
um it's so easy it comes to you so
naturally
uh rewind you know uh six centuries
seven centuries uh it wouldn't have come
naturally at all
uh you know i was drawing cubes i don't
know what age but pretty young and
that's not because i'm a genius or a
prodigy or
some da vinci tear you know mega genius
it's because of uh cultural osmosis
because
the ideas that we just take for granted
we inherit but someone had to come up
with them
and well often lots of people have to
come up with them
and it takes uh you know centuries
decades of effort of hard work
of error correction uh of finding out
the ways in which we are so severely
wrong about the world
um and yeah so to tie up my point um
thinking being able to even notice these
risks uh
the risks facing humanity or just the
fact of how bad
uh human extinction would be um those
are really
uh huge achievements and they're quite
modern ones as well
uh so yeah i would say i would put it
like this
it's it's a it's a uh it's a cure for
despondency
um because like i said it's easy to see
the risks ahead
uh harder to see how far we've come so
it's easy to be despondent it's easy to
despair
um but it's deceptively easy because we
have that kind of bias where it's
easier to look straight ahead rather
than look to the past are you trying to
say that a book about the annihilation
of humanity is somehow hopeful
yes so i i often get this when uh
people uh read my book they they uh
are surprised that um it has this well
it attempts
it attempts to have this this hopeful
message um
but yeah nonetheless it does it does uh
you know and and funnily enough i came
into all this
way less hopeful and i'm not sure if
it would be the perfect the right word
but um
more fatalistic um and it was through
actually like
tinkering through tracing through uh the
contours of like discovery
and intellectual progress and you know
just how far we've come in terms of
you know even if we know that we're not
true or we have 100 certainty of
anything right now
uh there's just the about the ability to
realize that we're wrong
right to realize that we're wrong and
therefore realize that we can know
better
uh we can correct ourselves i find that
fascinating so yeah um
yeah i think it's a hopeful book uh i
hope it's a hopeful book
i think so you mentioned there i think
quite an important point you say the the
ability to grasp the prospect of our own
extinction
is a significant intellectual
achievement it separates us from other
animals
are you also trying to say that that's
something that we should be thankful for
this species-wide denial of death that
ernest becker
like turned up to a million would be
proud of
yeah i mean so there's
uh there's a a jonathan shell he was a
guy that wrote about the face of the
earth in the 1980s um
and it was one of the first books it's
relevant to this discussion because it
was one of the first books to
really like crisply state how bad human
extinction would be
so this was in the context of the cold
war um
thermonuclear proliferation uh
and he amongst other people and we can
we can talk about this later if we want
but
amongst other people pointed out this
kind of asymmetry and how bad
extinction is compared to lots of other
you know kind of disasters
is that it's the foreclosure of the
whole future um
the way one of the ways in which uh
shell expressed this
was that there are these two deaths so
the first death is the death that we're
all
kind of familiar with uh our own death
our individual death
and so that's the kind of ernst becker
denial of death you know a lot of
culture um
is in a sense kind of you know seems to
be this that humans have this unique
awareness of our immortality
um i i'm not i'm not too familiar with
the becca thesis but like you know
say that say that was clearly one of one
of the kind of foundations of culture
right humans since they started using
language became behaviorally modern
uh have probably been kind of aware of
mortality in that sense
um but yeah then charles makes this
point that there's this second death
uh which is the death of the whole
species and the loss of its entire
future
um and that's the more modern
achievement so
uh yeah we've been denying death since
day one i guess but
uh being able to think about this second
death this you know
ultimate fate the loss of the entire
future um yeah
that's a lot more recent uh and so i'm
hoping that we can level up our denial
of death to that kind of civilization
scale
that's so funny can you give for the
uninitiated
for the people that haven't taken the
existential risk red pill
what is the most compelling hammer blow
that you can give them about why there
is an importance to existential risk
i'm already one of the initiates right i
pray at the altar
i wear the weird mask with the long crow
nose on it like
you don't need to convince me but what
to you is the
hit in the existential soul example that
you can give people
um yeah yeah so so so for me the kind of
penny drop
um uh the best place i've seen it argued
uh is um a philosopher derek parfit
um actually was nick bostrom's uh
one of his teachers supervisors um
so and this is around the same time as
that jonathan shell book that i just
mentioned
so in the in the 80s uh he wrote this uh
book called reasons and persons uh and
it's you know this kind of
voluminous uh meticulous tone of uh
you know kind of um uh very detailed
ethical philosophy
um and it's it's a masterwork uh you
know um but it's
you know kind of deeply philosophical
deeply complex but in the last couple of
pages he makes this argument
um about that asymmetry that i just
pointed to
um and he so he makes i think this is
the best place this argument has been
made so i'll try and rehearse it
so he says think of three scenarios uh
the first one is peace the second one
is a a nuclear exchange wherein
uh 95 to 99 of humans uh are killed
uh the third one is uh is some kind of
exchange where 100
of people are killed uh and then he says
where is the biggest difference is it
between one and two so between peace
and 95 to 99 or is it between
the 95 to 99 and 100
now intuitively and you know our moral
intuitions often wrong
uh intuitively you might kind of think
instantly well obviously
it's the difference between the first
you know the first and the second is the
difference between peace and
you know the the 95 to 99 percent
fatality
uh perfect makes uh the argument that
that's absolutely not the case the
larger distinction uh the larger
difference in severity
is between two and three uh and that's
because
again it's the loss of the whole future
uh
so he makes uh these points that you
know the earth is likely to remain
habitable for another billion years or
so
uh within that time uh there will be
vastly more generations of humans than
there already have been
uh so you know civilization itself has
only existed for
like something like 10 000 years um
so if we don't screw things up uh
there's
a lot of future ahead of us uh a whole
lot of future
and this is just constraining it's the
earth right uh there are other places we
can go
and other places where we can have even
more future
uh so basically we're kind of in the
daybreak
of uh civilization of the human story
um and so since then you know uh
other people have uh extended uh
parfit's argument
and it's so funny to me that perfect
kind of it's like a throwaway in the
last couple of pages of this
this huge book um but you know namely
it's uh
nick bostrom for example he uh kind of
formalized the concept of
central risk uh you know the first paper
where he talks about
it is from 2002 or 2003
um and he makes this further point uh
coming from
uh this kind of transhumanist lens where
um
it's not just kind of the duration of
the future it's also
how much more quality that could be in
it because you know
should humans use their technology in
the right way uh
there's this whole kind of possibility
space of
other experiences uh above the human
condition
um so you know i think a a way that
people often put it
is that you know uh mice probably aren't
very good at experiencing symphonies
uh but we are uh so there's presumably
kind of there's presumably headroom
above us
right you know there's kind of orders of
magnitude potentially uh
so you add this extra transhumanist kind
of uh
you know um uh spin on it um
and yeah i think all the pieces are
together there
um you know uh toby ord's now uh kind of
given an even more uh even simpler uh
and even more effective possibly
definition of the whole thing
uh but yeah for me it's those arguments
that really um
really drive at home uh you know um
particularly the perfect one you know
it's it's
it's easy to uh miss that fact
uh that you know it's not just uh seven
billion lives at stake
uh it's not just you know the current
population of the world
it's our whole future and our whole
potential as well
didn't bostrom come up with a number of
ten with a hundred zeros after it
isn't that in your book if we do an
okay amount of space colonization this
is the potential number of lives that we
could have ahead of us
yeah yeah so there are there is there
are huge numbers out there so um
uh bostrom has this paper uh uh it's
called uh
astronomical waste uh where he makes
this argument that there's like a kind
of
opportunity cost uh for
you know um delaying um
space colonization uh given that there's
you know
there is actually finite uh resource um
within the the the kind of accessible
universe
it's appreciatingly finite as well right
for every second that we don't that's
another bit of expansion that we can
never
anymore access yeah yeah so he makes
this argument that
you know uh we could expand out and
uh you know create so many value
structures and yeah that's his word for
kind of people
or you know uh functional equivalence of
people living happy
uh quality filled lives uh and there
yeah there are these computations of the
the kind of upper bound of amount of
uh you know souls that we could spread
throughout the universe
um uh one of bostrom's colleagues uh
milan zerkovic
uh he uh came up with a figure before
then i i think it's some it's it's like
a it's a kind of
crazy uh number it's like a quadrilector
alien or something i can't even
pronounce it it's humongous but yeah you
know
go to those papers for the precise the
precise
uh figures but um yeah i mean so so
uh you know there's there's a
depreciating amount of this potential as
well but um more recently there's been
this kind of
uh so odd calculates that um you know
the
the
kind of opportunity cost of delaying is
potentially
you know not too awful and so we should
be patient
and uh shouldn't you know kind of rush
ahead if that uh
can you know um foreclose our potential
if we are too hasty i'm going to jump
ahead to something i've been thinking
about for ages and
you sadly thomas have the job of being
um the recipient of all of my
bent pent-up x-risk
ideas um because i don't get to talk
about it to everyone
for some reason not everyone wants to
talk about the extinction of permanent
and ultimate extinction of the human
race
so it's you and now thousands of people
that are listening as far as i can see
it there seems to be three main factors
at play
right when we're talking about
existential risk and how we should
potentially move forward
the first one being the danger of
technological progress as bostrom calls
it the putting
the hand into the urn and pulling out a
technology this technology
could be good and improve human life but
every so often you pull out one which is
either gray or black
if you pull out a misaligned super
intelligence then you
you're dead game over and if you pull
out uh nano technology turns us all into
grey goo then you're dead and if you
pull out an engineered pandemic then
you're dead
um so that's first bit need there is a
danger that's associated with
technological progress
secondly there is a requirement of
technological protection
because there is a non-zero amount of
natural risk
there are volcanoes and there are
asteroids and there is the inevitable
heat death of
the sun and we're gonna you know we need
to continue to technology could progress
or else we assure that we're going to
have a limited future because we know
that there is a non-zero amount of
existential risk that occurs naturally
so there's a balance between those two
and then the final part is the
opportunity cost of delaying space
colonization
is that an okay framework to kind of
view what we should be doing moving
forward
that there is an opportunity cost there
is a requirement for us to not move too
quickly as to pull out black ball
and that by moving a little bit more
slowly that we reduce the risk of
pulling out black ball
but also we can't not move forward at
all because there is the natural risk
um yeah yeah i think i think that's a
good way of um
like taxonomizing the major uh parts of
the
the the argument um yeah it's it's
it's uh precisely as you say it's this
you know um
mature acknowledgement of the risks uh
of
technology but conjoined with
a mature acknowledgement of just how
good
uh technology could create the you know
could could make the future but then
also
yes that also the other acknowledgement
that um
without technology uh kind of background
natural risks will you know the
probability will accumulate over time
and yeah it's a death sentence
uh it's just a delayed one right um
you know so yeah yeah i mean and that's
what's novel about it
um historically speaking
um and so you know we can go into the
long the long run history of this stuff
because you know that's
that's what i love but um you know it's
people have been
uh talking about human extinction
like as a uh you know as a natural
possibility
for um i would say you know kind of uh
three centuries two centuries somewhere
in that ballpark
um you know uh then
it becomes uh during that time with you
know we're talking kind of scientists
during the enlightenment
uh you know they're kind of playing
around with it as this uh
you know interesting philosophical uh
natural philosophical possibility
um but it remains very kind of distant
very far off
um and then you know
it's really around world war ii uh
and uh the production of nuclear weapons
um and then you know uh
these humongous uh nuclear weapons like
uh the tsar bomb
and you know these kind of really
significantly powerful ones um
in the 1950s um that
the idea of you know uh the idea of
human extinction which had previously
just been possible
becomes slightly more probable plausible
uh and therefore a policy issue so
people have been talking about
you know this worst case scenario for
for for
for decades but often it was constrained
to uh one technology that being
uh nuclear weapons um
and uh often they were kind of like kind
of these
quite um distinct poles of thinking
where you know um it's
often this kind of um idea that you know
uh we need to just rush towards
technology have it all
uh that's that's what will save us or oh
no technology is bad we should
uh you know kind of um be careful with
what we do with it
this is what's innovative around um you
know boston's work and
people in that kind of area is this you
know mature acknowledgement that
it's you know the poison and the cure
and therefore requires lots of care
um and uh lots of
careful thinking and um you know
what's really great is it's kind of
giving a shot in the arm to philosophy
because it's you know there are these
philosophical questions that we need to
figure out before
we have the you know the the the the
technologies
uh to wield that you know wield the
power on the world so
uh so yeah that's that's how i see it
and that's why i say it's important yeah
as far as i can see man it is the most
important conversation
to have it is it blows my mind
that we have greta thundberg rolling
around
going on a pedalo from [ __ ] south
america back to europe or whatever to
try and reduce her carbon footprint
to talk about a problem which is going
to affect us
on an existential risk scale in
millennia
and we don't have any i mean in the
nicest possible way
like nick nick spends a lot of time
working he's not fantastic with media
obligations i think he probably had to
save up
about seven seven months worth of his
allowance to go on the joe rogan
experience
and also the last hour of that podcast
was the most
painful hour of any podcast in history
um for anyone that doesn't know what i'm
talking about just listen to the first
hour and a half and then please do not
delve into the end of it
um so i want to get into kind of my
thoughts around culturally the problems
with existential risk but as you say
we've got this
this sort of wonderful research that
you've done to do with the history of
x-risk
you actually start with this kind of
cool timeline thing that's all drawn out
of the
the um the landmarks of the the life of
existential risk you mentioned the
existential risk in pre-history before
1600 bc was framed differently
to how it is now why um yeah yeah
so i would say that the the concept
simply didn't exist right
uh people couldn't think about it
um and again yeah this goes back to what
i was saying earlier is you know one of
the things that really
you know drives me and so yeah i mean
you know i'm just a historian
i'm interested in you know this this
amazing work this super important work
uh an existential risk but you know the
experts in that not me i'm
i go through and i try and you know tell
the story of how we got here which i
again like i said i think that's
important uh
moving forwards because people so often
fail to
um notice the potential of humanity and
part of that potential is looking
backwards
as we were talking about anyway so you
know there are times when there are new
ideas
uh you know um ideas that haven't
occurred to anyone before
um so the the obvious ones
uh that i think you know most people are
familiar with are
things like you know darwin's theory of
natural selection
um you can go back and you can find uh
you know you can pick through the
ancient greeks and you can find
someone here and there saying oh maybe
maybe uh humans used to be fish
um that's not that's not a theory of
natural selection you know
um so often the way that like uh history
is done when it comes to the history of
ideas
uh it's a case of people kind of picking
back through the past and going
oh here's something that looks like this
new idea um
and so that's that's absolutely the
opposite of what what i wanted to do
um i wanted to go no this thinking is
new and that's why it's important
um so you can go back and you can find
uh these kind of uh you know the greats
of uh ancient greek
uh philosophy uh talking about things
that
deceptively look a bit like extinction
events right
um so you know humans have always loved
massive catastrophes
uh we've always loved to to narrative
eyes to talk about
huge disasters calamities you know
pyrotechnic volcanic explosions
you know you name it um you can find
plato
uh he he so the myth of atlantis right
uh
that's that's one of plato's kind of um
you know
it's a thing that he talks about and he
talks about these cataclysms that have
wiped
uh civilization from the earth in the
past
um but then he says as as humanity will
be wiped from the earth in the future
so you can start to notice that there's
a cycle occurring here
uh so plato aristotle a lot of these
kind of ancient authors they would talk
of these massive catastrophes
but the important thing is uh they were
presuming that after
the catastrophe uh humanity would return
or
recover a civilization would kind of
just happen again
um so you know it's it's
that's not an existential risk because
the important thing
in existential risk is the
irreversibility
it's the fact that uh our potential is
lost forever
um the human species is gone forever
uh therefore you know it won't ever
realize that potential
um the very idea that a species could
disappear
and never return uh is a really modern
idea as well
like all of these ancient philosophers
uh
spent most of their time thinking that
uh
you know if a species disappears um
it doesn't matter because it'll kind of
uh it'll uh continue to exist elsewhere
or it'll just return at another time
um so you can find you can find them
saying stuff like this there's one in
particular
uh lucretius a roman philosopher um
and he talks about um he talks about
you know uh uh the earth is aging right
uh
it's kind of falling apart it's uh
losing its uh
you know kind of um it's losing its uh
life force is kind of the way he talks
about
it um and so again you might think this
looks like oh he's talking about
something like entropy or you know
but he's not because he says nothing in
creation is the only one
uh nothing in nature ever is ever
destroyed because
um if it's destroyed here it will
re-emerge at some other point in the
vastness
of the cosmic infinity um and so this is
a really important idea
uh that took a long time to dismantle is
this
uh this confidence
that uh nothing can ever really be lost
from nature
uh so be that species be like the dodo
or be that
basically value uh so
the recognition the acknowledgement that
value and the potential to create value
uh can be irreversibly lost
um yeah it's a really modern one uh and
like i said you know that's super
important uh because
you know um you know we often talk about
these
huge revolutions in the way we think uh
you know um
[Music]
darwin's theory of natural selection it
it it completely changes how we relate
to
ourselves in this universe uh you know
it completely changes how we think about
what we are and what we can do
this is another one that hasn't really
been written about or noticed yet is
uh you know this recognition that yeah
if um
you know if if if humanity is lost if
uh we lose our potential if we destroy
it uh
through our own folly or uh you know
through
insignificant record uh you know
insufficient precaution
um that's it forever that's a really
important idea
and it's yeah it's a really new one as
well what was the first
existential risk that humans faced as a
species was there something in in
paleolithic ancestry where we got down
to a population of 12 or something like
that
yeah so there's this theory and it's i
stress theory uh there's been
um there's been some work more recently
that's question p put this into question
but there is this uh this this idea
that uh at some point um
i think it's uh 75 000 years ago uh
there was this
uh super eruption uh is the
toba uh super volcano um
toba i think it's in indonesia um so
this and we're talking ginormous like
you know uh
there's a cool graph uh if you google
toba
um you'll be able to see it it's it's uh
it's a graph of like the size of the
volcanic eruptions ranked
and some of the you know the ones that
are kind of more memorable like krakatoa
they're just like absolute they're like
pimples compared to toba it was huge
um so yeah this absolutely ginormous um
volcanic eruption uh the theory is that
it created a
um uh population um
bottleneck uh because it uh the climatic
format fallout
um seems to have you know um this is
we're talking kind of early
um uh you know kind of
early behaviorally modern humans so
that's like
you know when we were kind of you know
talking doing culture um
[Music]
there's evidence that you know the
population like really narrows down
uh um through genetics there's this kind
of evidence for this
um at this point and it kind of you know
the dates line up nicely with toba
um so yeah again like i said it's been
put into question more recently but
there is you know there is some evidence
to show that humanity has come
close to the knife edge before um and
you know that's not surprising
because 99.9 of all species that have
ever existed
uh are now extinct so it's extinction is
the rule uh you know uh survival is the
exception
so um yeah like you know i think that's
that's that's an important
that's an important thing to know is
that you know potentially we have come
close before
uh you know this isn't um you know this
isn't uh
you know something that is completely
unprecedented
indonesia would have been a real hot
spot as well because that's where an
awful lot of humans developed from right
and
i think it was only 12 000 years ago
that you had
a different homo species that was still
existing you had this sort of pygmy
sized miniature
human species that was still existing so
75 000 years ago you'd have probably
still had neanderthals you would have
had homo sapiens you would have had a
few others so it potentially would have
caused this bottleneck
for all of them and then maybe we didn't
make it out the other side
and i think that that probably
highlights one of the real
um importances with regards to displace
space exploration
and just setting up a colony somewhere
else
you know we can look at elon going to
mars and say well it's spending a lot of
money
and it's taking up we could be spending
this on
inequality or on world hungers and stuff
like that but
from a civilization god's eye view
this is super important we need to get
ourselves off indonesia because if the
volcano decides to erupt
and that can occur in any one of a
number of different ways we also need to
make sure that there is no internet
connection
between us and mars that maligned
artificial general intelligence is not
allowed to get up there as well but my
point is like
that that really sort of quite nicely i
think demonstrates
how precarious because we look at that
and we think oh yeah
but you know they didn't have technology
and there was only a small number you
may be talking i don't know
50 000 humans at mo i don't know it
could be it's not going to be more than
a few million humans
definitely not such a small number how
could that occur you realize
that is just uh an inability to judge
scale
correctly that for every size that you
go up there is an equivalent catastrophe
that could then completely annihilate it
so what about the first record of
a human thinking about our own
extinction was it
was there some philosopher in the in
ancient greece that you found
nostra bostradamus
uh all of the people from uh
from uh so kind of you know ancient
um classical so we're talking about
ancient greeks romans
um yeah they're always when they're
talking about these big cataclysms it's
always the case
um as far as as far as you know in my
opinion
that uh these are kind of
false friends so this is a this is an
idea i take from linguistics is uh
um there are words where you know in one
language
uh they well they sound the same in two
languages but mean very different things
right
um so i think a good example is das gift
in german means poison so not a gift
not a gift yeah um so i think you get
false friends in uh
in in concepts as well so um
you know uh like i was saying earlier
plato talking about these
huge the word he uses conflagration so
this is like you know fire burning up
the world he says the whole surface of
the world has uh
suffered these conflagrations that have
wiped out humanity
um but you know then goes oh as it all
happens humanity again in the future so
it's just part of this cycles i was
mentioning
that's a false friend because on the
surface if you just read that sentence
it's like oh plato had this kind of you
know
nascent uh you know uh theory
this in kuwait theory of um
conflagration as a as a risk uh you know
a civilizational risk but it's not
because
again it's not irreversible yeah exactly
exactly exactly
so um yeah all of these uh pre-modern
uh thinkers uh it's yeah
there's always this strange sense where
they talk about
these you know huge disasters these
global
um you know um uh
burnings or freezings uh those are the
things that seem to attract our
intuitions we love fire and ice
um uh but it's always yeah within this
confidence
of um you know everything lost will
later return
uh who gets a hat then who's the who's
the first person that does it properly
um so there's this kind of um it's very
gradual
uh so we're talking um you know the
scientific revolution that kind of
swings around like
fifteen hundred sixteen hundred uh
people start to think scientifically
um you might think that that would kind
of instantly knock
all of this kind of naive thinking um
out of the way but it really doesn't you
know there's this thing
when you work with like the history of
ideas uh
there's this really persistent um thing
i call conceptual inertia
uh where you know old ways of thinking
persist
into new frameworks and do so very
stubbornly often
uh and so i'm sure we're suffering from
a lot of it now that hopefully our
forebears
if we make it out of the precipice uh
will look back on us
and see how uh you know see how naive we
were
but um yeah so there's conceptual
inertia in the scientific revolution
uh is you know do you have this big
shift in world view uh to do with
people realizing that we're not the
center of the universe um
so this is the copernican revolution um
the medievals thought that you know uh
that the sun goes around the earth uh
kepler copernicus these scientists they
completely changed that
so you might think people are thinking
differently now they might start to
think that you know if humanity
disappears that would actually be it
that would be really bad because we're
this one planet
in this you know cosmic uh cosmic void
this massive
uh expanse they didn't uh
so you know you get um
people uh so there's some of the
original the first scientists
uh so uh edmund halley uh uh robert hook
these are the
these kind of pioneers of science um
they started to think
um geologically about the history of the
planet uh they started to say oh there
are these huge catastrophes in the past
like massive earthquakes that probably
completely reorganize the surface of the
earth
um but
well actually halley's very interesting
because he says um
you know every time this will white
civilization it will have re-emerged
um it's such a shame that we've lost all
of the achievements of that previous
civilization they might have
had this learned age where they reach
peaks of knowledge
way higher than us uh it's just a shame
that you know
um we'll have to kind of catch up to
them um
so even though they're thinking
geologically scientifically
naturalistically
uh there's still this obstruction here
and the other way that this is expressed
and this is a really important one
is um and this is to do with this this
copernican revolution this revelation of
how huge the universe is
um so
people would look at these other planets
uh well not actually look at them that
happened a lot later but they would
theorize about uh
how you know all these other stars these
are you know pricks of light in the sky
uh there are the stars and they must
have plants like our own revolving
around them
and they thought oh it would be an awful
waste of space
uh if they weren't populated um
so yeah they probably have uh all of
them probably have aliens on them
and people also presumed that these
aliens were actually basically humanoid
uh or um you know were interested in
values
that were like ours uh so
you have this really high confidence
that
you know humans pretty much exist
everywhere or if not humans
the values that matter to us uh
so you know there wasn't there wasn't
really a sense of there being any kind
of um
uh possibility for you know wasted
opportunity for values or kind of
vacuums where there is no value
value was thought to exist throughout
the whole universe it basically like
fills it up
you know um this is this idea called the
principle of plenitude
um so you had to dismantle that before
you get this person who gets the hat
of being the first person to go oh maybe
this would really matter
and yeah it's not as simple as that
unfortunately you know there's no one
person who goes oh
if humanity's gone that's it forever um
you know you find people kind of at the
beginning of the 1700s
uh particularly um towards the end of
the 1700s starting to play around with
the idea
of human extinction um
and this idea that you know we might
disappear
the exact same thing might not re-emerge
um
so there's you know and this is when
people started to dig up bones of
you know prehistoric beasts um and
started to realize that actually there
are animals that you know have
disappeared and are gone forever so
again this irreversibility starts to
kind of
you know trickle into the picture um
but still i mean a really good example
is from dennis dittero
this like you know kind of massive uh
minded the french enlightenment
um and you know he was at this uh dinner
party
uh with his other friends you know they
were probably talking about regicide and
guillotining the king
uh but during one of these conversations
uh one of them asks didoro
who you know had these kind of um uh
you know quite um iconoclastic uh
materialist theories uh so materialist
there means that you know he was just
being quite mature and saying maybe
spirits and supernatural things don't
exist
so they asked him at this dinner party
they said um
can humanity go extinct uh and diderot
said
yes it can um but
you know uh it would just re-evolve
again
in you know uh however many millions of
years uh
so yeah you know it's it's it's it's
this kind of gradual process i mean
funnily enough
um and let's actually i'm going to give
you a definitive answer here uh the
person who gets the hat is one of
diderot's friends um
he was another french philosopher called
uh baron de olbach and he
uh actually has said uh he said
we cannot be sure that all these other
planets
uh contain humans and that humans are
there for the natural end
of all kind of uh all evolution uh
all natural history obviously evolution
not in the darwinian sense back then
uh but he said that and then said you
know
thus therefore if our planet was you
know knocked off its course
that could be it for humanity so yeah i
think you know
let's give him the hat he's the first
person to uh you know say
yeah uh a head of evidence we can't just
assume that humans are everywhere and
values human values everywhere
b we can't assume that they're the end
of everything the purpose of this whole
cosmos that we live in
uh and see therefore we can't be sure
again
ahead of good evidence that uh if we
screw it up um
you know something else will just
re-evolve like us
i think that that really explains nicely
the answer to the first question that i
gave you about
why is it important for us to look back
and
given that we're in the scientific
post-scientific world utilitarian
rationalists i can scott alexander my
way to an eliezer yukowski blog and i
understand my cognitive biases and
like we we believe that we have reality
in our grasp
but the intellectual inertia cognitive
inertia that you just mentioned there
the principle of plentitude as well this
presumption that everything will be okay
when you combine that with is it scope
insensitivity
skype neglect scott neglect that's it
sorry um that
big things are really really hard for us
to to work out and as you scale
up small things to big things the death
of a person
the death of two people doesn't feel as
bad as the death of one person
and the death of a million people
doesn't feel a million times worse than
the death of one person
so when you combine all of that together
i think it
it starts to get us to a place where
those of us who want to force the
existential red pill down everybody's
throats
actually start to understand why
it might be a little bit of a a big
medication to swallow
um wasn't it thomas jefferson
was famous for believing that some
animals or that no animals ever went
extinct and you think thomas
thomas jefferson's like he's modern
history you know there's like
drawings of him and paintings and stuff
like that and he was part of a country
that's still around now
yeah yeah definitely so i mean
if there's anything that my daily work
is it's uh
just cataloging the vast library of how
often we're wrong
uh and and and not just you know um
you know uh normal people but these
huge uh these huge great minds so yeah
like you know
thomas jefferson yeah he's a great
example so um
you know this goes back to um what i was
just talking about with
you know in the 1700s people started
unearthing these
these huge bones uh of you know
fossilized bones of unknown beasts
and you know prior to this i think this
is an interesting context actually prior
to their scientists
um and natural philosophers
uh presumed that fossils were um
they didn't think that they were um the
kind of
impressions of prehistoric animals um
that was again i think this is a great
example of what we were talking about
earlier
of uh you know it seems so obvious now
uh that fossils are you know kind of
the evidence of prehistoric animals like
you know when you're a kid and you watch
jurassic park like you understand that
uh but this took centuries for people to
figure out uh
so the medieval theory so during the
middle ages uh
what people thought was that um
these strange animalistic imprints in
rocks
uh were actually nature playing jokes on
us
uh so they had this idea of the kind of
scale of being
the great chain of being so it's that
everything is in this kind of ordered
uh hierarchy uh from you know
rocks to plants to oysters to
monkeys to man and they thought that
fossils were evidence of where rocks had
like uh basically become upstart and
wanted to
you know jump above their um their their
their office basically
uh so you know this is this is this is
how people thought
and you know it's it's i i i find it
really charming and i love it but you
know
it's it's yeah again people can be so
wrong for them you know
yeah we're often very wrong about a lot
of things so this is how people thought
for a long time about these fossils da
vinci was one of the first people to go
hang on maybe these are impressions of
uh of animals from you know the deep
past
um and yeah so you know
people used to kind of study it was
mainly shells like small
uh you know small um small
fossils that was very easy to say
you know this animal uh we might not see
it in our kind of vicinity
uh alive we might only have fossil
evidence of it but it probably exists
somewhere else in the world
um and that was how people uh you know
for a long time
got around the fact that we had evidence
of fossils
but we don't want to accept species
extinctions or the possibility that
nature could irreversibly again
irreversibly
lose uh any part of it
uh and so this was this kind of you know
tricky maneuver that all these very
clever scientists took to deny the
possibility of extinction of anything
um you know yeah then
people started finding mammoth bones
mastered on bones uh
and people started to accept scientists
started to accept that
perhaps species extinction was a thing
that has happened and will happen again
um and this was in the late 1700s uh
thomas jefferson yeah he still thought
this
even up until the point when uh you know
scientific contents was reached so it's
like in the 1780s he was still writing
letters to people
very confidently claiming that mammoths
uh
still exist in the uh kind of unexplored
regions of the americas
so we just need to go and find a mammoth
and then you know we don't need to worry
about extinction anymore
um so so yeah yeah no you're right
you're absolutely right to link this up
into
uh you know the kind of prevalence of
bias and wrong think uh yeah it's it you
know
i want to give this hopeful message of
you know how far we've come
and how important all that is uh but at
the same time
you know you only reach that by seeing
how how
you know vastly wrong we often are yeah
every age has probably had its
cassandras right the
the people that were certain that the
end was on its way
and you highlight some differences
between extinction and apocalypse
and between prophecy and prediction can
you
lay out how all of this works for us
yeah so um i guess
listeners might have already thought you
know what's this guy talking about
people have been thinking about the end
of the world forever uh have you
i often have you not read the bible
exactly
exactly i often get that comment it's uh
yeah it's it's one of the more common
uh comments is this judgment day yeah
exactly
yeah has this guy not read the book of
revelations um
so yeah the claim i make is the
apocalypse is distinct from extinction
uh and
what i mean by that is that you know you
look at
um the end of the world as it's
presented in religious traditions and
mythological traditions
uh and often uh it's seen as the
consummation or the fulfillment of the
moral order
uh so what i mean by that is think of
um think of judgement day the christian
version
it's it's just in the words judgment day
it's
the the revelation of how god thinks
everything should be
so it's the conservation of morality
it's not like you know it's not anything
bad even though we might be it might be
very inscrutable to us mere mortals
uh we might not be able to understand it
fully you know god's decree
that tribunal is ultimately the right
decree so
you know another image that um pops up
is this idea of
sorting the good from the bad that's
what the end of the world judgment day
is kind of this point where
uh the good from the bad is all fully
sorted everything's in its right place
and that's the end and you know then the
curtains can close
um that's not actually a bad thing it
might be the end of time but
it's you know it's actually really great
like uh
like i said morality is fulfilled in
this instance
so in the modern naturalistic scientific
idea of extinction
it's completely different it's not just
you know
a new version of that old idea of
apocalypse it's actually a
contradictory concept because instead of
the um the ultimate
uh fulfillment of morality it's the
irreversible frustration of it
um at least you know kind of human
morality and and
going back to this point about aliens
and other planets uh
as far as we know we're the only uh
animal that
follows ethical argumentation that's
able to you know kind of
think about um moral reasons and what
should be and what shouldn't be
um so you know if we're gone
all of that is frustrated potentially
irreversibly
um and that's really important you know
those are completely contradictory
ways of looking at this uh so there's a
pithy way that i like to put it is that
uh
you know apocalypse supplies a sense of
an ending
uh whereas extinction uh anticipates the
ending of scent
um so it's this idea
that uh you know meaning
and purpose are irreversibly frustrated
within this
vast physical cosmos this vast silent
physical cosmos that
continues quasi-purposely uh
without us and yeah yeah as a final
point that's also just a really simple
uh another point to make a really simple
one is that
um often in religious apocalypses uh
the physical cosmos doesn't go on
without us it ends with us
um or it's again nested in these cycles
so
a lot of uh eastern kind of ideas so the
buddhist
apocalypse it's you know this cyclical
you know the world ends it gets reborn
it burns it gets recreated
um so yeah you know nothing's at stake
in apocalypse whereas in extinction
everything is at stake it's like
an egotistic metaphysical
uh copernican view of ourselves
right that the earth the center of the
universe but not only that
we are the center of the universe and
not only are we the center of the
universe
we are the bookend to the universe
because without us
what is the point of the universe but
oddly that line of reasoning
without us what is the point of the
universe is still what we're continuing
forward now
the two potential
answers that we have to the fermi
paradox of where are all the aliens one
is there aren't any it's just us the
other is they're out there
both of them are fascinating both of
them are terrifying but they do have
slightly presuming that the aliens that
we're talking about also have morality
and the ability to step into their own
ethics and stuff like that
the differences are quite profound
because it is the difference between
being
every other semi-sentient being
bottlenose dolphins and
and bonobos and stuff like that isn't
crew aboard spaceship earth
they're cargo we are crew
we can affect the direction of what is
going to happen
we can save the other animals we can
allow them to exist at greater and
greater
levels of comfort and of bliss
and of happiness right and we can also
do that to ourselves and then we can
scale that across the universe
um it's so interesting to see
this apocalyptic approach the
it is it very much is a a very ego
driven
sort of copernican centrist this
human-centric
view of everything and why wouldn't it
be that way when you told that god built
the world
and the universe in six days and the
most important thing that he built was
on the sixth day
and it was the humans etc etc
all of your culture all of your stories
all the narratives that you've been
given
are telling you this is why everything
is here you are why
everything is here this is how special
you are and
i think this might also highlight why i
love
existential risk so much that it's the
same as looking at the night sky it
provides an equal amount of ore
and dread and it reminds me that the
universe
very very much is indifferent whether or
not we continue going on
and it is our stone to roll up the hill
if we want to do it um
and yeah upon realizing that i i think
that also probably highlights
why the denial of death thing from
ernest becker kind of
gets macro aggregated across people with
this it's a very uncomfortable topic to
think about
because it reminds you that no one's
coming to save you
no one gives a [ __ ] nothing cares
about whether or not we continue to
exist or not except for us which means
it's all on us
there is risk there is responsibility
and
the book stops with us yeah yeah i could
i couldn't agree more
um if there's one if there's one major
theme
of uh what i've written on this history
it's
the it's breaking the spell on that kind
of wishful thinking
um where we allow
what we want the world to be to
contaminate our theories
of what the world actually is so
really broad brush generalization and of
being unfair to
lots of very clever people that came
before us and whose
shoulders that we stand upon but the
pre-modern world view
often you know isn't often doesn't
really even think
uh that there's a distinction between
ethics and physics
uh what i mean by that is you know
take for example the the the medieval
cosmos um
you know this is the pre-copernican one
the idea of earth in the center
there are these uh concentric nested
spheres
uh and not at the edge there's this prim
and mobile it's the outer sphere that's
where god lives that's where all the
value the best stuff is
um all of those spheres is populated
with
hierarchies of angels uh you know the
whole thing there's value suffusing the
whole thing
um but the very structure of the cosmos
right
the whole the whole structure is
the moral order so that's what i mean by
there's no distinction between ethics
and physics there
i perceive you know part of the uh
what kick-started science and um
you know not just science has this you
know
disinterested objective endeavor of
finding out you know
uh the how things hang together how the
facts hang together in the broadest
possible sense
but this newer idea of how we can then
knowing those facts get our values to
fit together
with this picture in the broadest
possible sense so i guess i mean
what is to be done you know we've
learned a lot about the cosmos
uh the objective physical you know
uninterested uh unresponsive cosmos and
independence of us
we've learnt a lot about that but now
we're asking this question of how do our
values how could our values
um uh fit into this
and yeah i see this is this is all part
of this um
this picture so yeah you have to kind of
um basically shake off that wishful
thinking
of thinking that you know in
independence of what we do the universe
is just a great place
and uh you know kind of aligns with our
values no matter what um which i think
is
the default way of um of human thinking
so you know uh there's this idea
um of uh in the philosophy of science of
folk psychology
um where or another word for it is the
manifest image
um as opposed to the scientific image uh
the manifest image is you know
our picture of the world as filled with
colors
intentions emotions uh all the things
that we're used to on our daily
daily lives the scientific image is this
really barren
alien place that's made up of atoms
electrons
uh you know subatomic forces um
you know you have to realize that
distinction and the fact that the way
the world actually is
is not the way we want it to be or it
should be or it ought to be
uh to then reintegrate and
think of well okay we've realized that
we've woken up we've broken the spell
uh how that what do we do next um
how do we make this world uh that you
know just is the way it is independently
of us
how do we make it into the one uh that
we want
uh or not just that we want but that
would be worthy
uh in some uh you know meaty and moral
sense um
and yeah this wide scale history that i
try and tell of us waking up to the
possibility of extinction it's this you
know
it's this kind of landmark event in that
it's realizing
that you know um everything rests on us
uh not because we're the center of the
universe but because the universe simply
doesn't care about us
um but strangely enough that also
kind of re-centralizes everything upon
us um you know until we find evidence to
the country
uh and i hope we do i i'm very hopeful
you know i
i want seti to be uh
you know a successful endeavor um i hope
there are wiser beings out there than us
uh but we can't just
act as if there are um ahead of that
evidence
so yeah it's this you know it's this
strange historical dance between
disillusion and um
you know that mature uh
that mature recognition of yeah i feel
alienated by the possibility of
extinction
uh in a way that you know uh the version
of me that lived 500 years ago just
simply couldn't be yeah i'm alienated by
that it terrifies me but
this is the thing i often say is you
know if if i'm
hurtling towards a cliff edge if i'm
driving you know 60 miles per hour
towards the cliff edge i want to know
where that cliff edge is uh rather than
just
wishfully thinking oh yeah i'll you know
the car will be fine i'll be fine
there's no cliffhanger
whatever so i see yeah um another way
you could put this is you know waking up
to extinction is kind of a
santa claus is a real moment for the
human race um
and yeah you know it might be
disillusioning it might be
uh upsetting it might be alienating but
it was
something that we needed to do if we
were to have a future um
so yeah i think it's again like i say
it's a massive achievement and
you know we need to keep that in view uh
with the future because i feel that you
know
it's so easy to be dis to be
disillusioned with
uh human potential uh to focus on
uh to focus on the kind of
the atrocities of the recent past
and think that that um think that that
there's an inevitability that that will
color the whole future
um so you know we need to
um i'm not saying that we don't we i'm
not saying that we should forget
you know these things but um
yeah i think that there's often there's
often it's particularly when we talk
about the space colonization discussion
there's often a kind of uh i refer to as
a geocentrism about history this idea
that we will repeat
just repeat everything um
you know all these kind of mistakes of
the past that's just what
spreading outwards will do c.s lewis has
this great quote where he you know says
i feel sorry for the aliens is basically
his sentiment
because you know us horrible sinners are
going to go out and
you know ruin the galaxy um
you know that's a form of geocentrism
just like
thinking that the earth is essentially
the universe thinking that our
um history colors our future and of
course it does in
an important sense but the work is
you know keeping an eye on the places
where real progress has happened and
seeing the capacity um
because and this goes back to the point
of you know
uh dolphins and uh you know marmosets
and you know all these other very
incredibly intelligent animals that we
share this planet with
um is one way of talking about you know
humans are the only animal that responds
to ethical argumentation that can sound
really abstract
really um kind of up in the clouds i
think a good way of making that concrete
is we're the only animal that's ever
corrected itself uh it's ever thought
oh what i previously thought was wrong
about what i should do or what i think
about the world
um so yeah we've been really wrong but
we have that capacity to correct
ourselves and that's the capacity to
make the world a better place
so um you know yeah i really like your
um the the cargo and uh and crew
uh i think toby this is the way that
toby ord puts it but um
is that you know animals are like moral
patients we're moral patients but also
moral
agents so you know i see there's a uh
you know the crew cargo is another way
of putting that so yeah i you know
um history can be hopeful yeah
i don't know what it is about this time
at the moment
everybody that's listening in yourself
knows and you have very
cleverly sort of managed to evade the
social justice precipice of saying that
there aren't any problems
right now and that we don't have
anything to fix in your little sort of
last monologue there
and it's because at the moment there are
to me it would appear that there is an
obsession
with injustices and many of them
are indeed injustices that need to be
fixed
but i think it discounts
so much of how far we've come it
discounts this view that you've given us
of just
how backward our views were when only
thomas jefferson
was on the planet not long ago
and yet when we have these times of
crises
when we have times of real serious
bloodshed and apocalypse and concerning
catastrophe
people have to center their values in
the time of a real crisis we focus our
values
in the time of no crisis we create our
own
and i think that the problem right now
is that people think
there is no crisis i don't think because
the existential risk the potential for
human catastrophe and the permanent and
irreversible
stop of the human pursuit
isn't there at the forefront of our
minds if we found out that there was a
meteor that was heading toward earth and
it was going to hit us within the next
1000 years
and we had it with certainty and the
news stories said the same
i think everybody would live life in a
very different sort of way
some ways better some ways worse but i
think it would bind us together as a
civilization i think it would stop us
from
focusing on things that in the grand
scheme of
human civilization don't matter as
tobiod says in the precipice
we are shuffling currently along this
cliff edge
it's real precarious um we only need to
do this for a little bit of time
i'm not saying that we need to
completely dispense with trying to fix
the wrongs that are going on in the
world
what i'm saying is that right now there
is a very very important job that needs
to be done by all of human civilization
and it is a game of whether or not we
get past it or we don't and if we don't
it doesn't matter how much social
injustice you've fixed
what i think that's led to and everybody
will know this sentiment at the moment
is this
oddly homo deprecating
view that the world has
where we talk about listen to people
talk about ecology and the environment
like as if we go out of our as if
dropping a can on the floor is because
you
hate the world as if because the fact
that you don't drive an electric car or
you don't get the bus to work or you
don't get the
cycle to work is because you actively
hate mother nature
and she's rebelling against us and we
just start personifying and adding
narratives like it's
like [ __ ] 2000 bc you know i mean
like we're just
layering all of this real primitive
thinking
that we've got about the sacred and the
profane meanwhile cardi b is on stage
singing about a whap and no one cares
so all of this bizarre
human hating that's going on both within
culture and within certain subgroups
within people
i think that a lot of that would be
fixed if we understood just how close we
are
to complete annihilation of everything
that you care about
of everything that your genetics down
the line can ever care about and of the
ability to
save the opportunity to step into
programming i think that's
what you said there the opportunity and
the ability for humans to step into
their own programming to redirect the
direction in which they are going
is what matters and um
man i really really hope that
the work of the guys at the future
humanities institute
continues to blow up we need
we needed greta thundberg of existential
risk and i mean that in
in a very very real way like we need a
front of time magazine social media
savvy
great speaker that gets the the world
behind them because it is the biggest
question that we all have
one thing that i haven't heard you talk
about and i'd love to know your opinion
on this
given the fact that you've done such a
broad view look
over this subject over the past of
history just how important do you think
this period of the last 30 years with
parfit and bostrom and ord
how much if you were drawing a graph in
terms of progress and understanding
how much of a hockey stick has that been
is it linear or has that really been a
marked
jump in our understanding around
existential risk
yeah i think um if you wanted to uh yeah
if
you had if you had had to you know
depict it pictorially i think it has
been yeah there's a step change
um and again you know this is one of my
senses from studying the history of
ideas and history of intellectual
progress
is um that that progress is often lumpy
and
you know kind of uneven and there's you
know it was kind of punctuated right
um and that's often because these ideas
require lots of
smaller sub ideas to come together so
you know you have it bubbling away
these sub ideas but they're not you know
converging
and then bam and i think we've just gone
through um
we've just gone through a point like
that so i mean
i'm hopeful about um i'm not despondent
about the fact that
you know not enough people are talking
about existential risk
i mean there's one thing to be sensitive
of is like you know thinking about the
long-term future and how all of our
potential vastly outweighs
you know uh you know the present and all
that stuff
there's this issue of fanaticism that
the community around this is very
aware of so it's this idea um that
you know uh basically
when you're thinking of these you know
huge potential ahead of us
uh it can outweigh you know
any sensible decision at the moment
because we'd want to vouch safe that
regardless of anything so you know this
is
this is something that you know
community is very self self conscious of
and it's an issue within you know this
tech very technical ethical
uh discussion um so that's yeah that's
one thing to
to be uh aware of um yeah another thing
is i'm hopeful because
um uh it's so it's
it's it's new that's why there aren't
many people that are talking about it
it's because it's
new uh these ideas haven't been around
for long and it often takes a while for
ideas to really catch on and
to start to trickle through the you know
relevant
uh streams the you know the relevant
institutions
um so yeah i think it's new it's it's
it's new and that's why
um and um
so i am hopeful that the discussion will
continue and i i don't think that um
uh you know people talking about other
things like
you know greta thornberg she's not like
taking resources from people to
talking about existential risks so and
you know climate change is
actually like it might not be an
existential risk in the sense they'll
uh you know destroy homo sapiens
all of them but it could actually
irreversibly
make our future poorer and less well-off
uh
so you know it's i think it has to you
have to you have to balance all these
things yeah
i agree thinking about something that
you brought up which i'd read in a book
ages ago
and i'd totally forgotten about and it's
absolutely fascinating can you explain
what the doomsday argument is please
yeah i'll give it a try so um
there's there's there's different
versions of it uh
and interestingly uh appear
around the same time independently so
this is another thing in the history of
science i'm
going to nerd out about the history of
science for a second is uh
often really great ideas um people
independently arrive upon them around
the same time
why do you think that i think it's again
similar to what i was talking about
earlier is uh
there are all these sub-component ideas
that require that are required
to uh then reach um
the big theory uh so natural selection
required
an awareness of species extinctions in
the past it requires an awareness of
population dynamics blah blah blah blah
blah
blah
so darwin came up with uh alfred russell
wallace
uh almost at the same time completely
independently
anyway doomsday argument um
basically uh you should applying the
copernican principle the principle of
mediocrity
um we should assume that we're in
a uh in a um unexceptionable
unexceptional uh place uh and that
applies
that principle can be applied very
broadly and so when you apply it to our
position
in human history uh so imagine
a reference class of all humans ever
born
uh ordered from um ordered temporarily
so obviously it's arbitrary the first
human ever is arbitrary in a sense
because
you know evolution uh but imagine first
human ever
last human humans ever um
we should we should assume that we're in
an unexceptional
unexceptional uh placement within that
broad
broad reference class right um
so given uh given one of the versions
makes the reference to population
uh and how population is expanded and uh
if humanity
survives into the long term will expand
a lot more
uh it's far more likely
that we are later on where there are
more people
uh so imagine this is a curve than we
are very early on
where there are barely any so the the
analogy that's often used
is um uh imagine
that uh imagine that you have an
uh a bag of balls um and
you someone someone told you that this
bag either has five balls in it or a
hundred balls in it
um and you pick the number four
uh you would rationally
presumed that you've got the bag with
the five balls
right um so applying that reasoning to
that
you know long-scale human race uh
you have you know you have to yeah the
the conclusion is
that we're probably living later on
towards the end
uh now this gets into all kinds of
thorny issues
um you know super complicated
uh kind of reasoning and
it's very interesting um uh and it's
very controversial as well
so um yeah i think the best place to go
to find out more about it is actually
the wikipedia page
um i think vox did quite a good
explainer on it as well but it's it's
it's a really fascinating argument um
really technical really complicated but
uh and i'll see you guys
there'll be a reddit thread somewhere
reddit explained everything i read it's
becoming like the new wikipedia
i think thinking about sort of looking
forward
what lessons can we learn from looking
at our extinction that
inform the enlightenment mission moving
forward how do we carry this
into the future so
i think that um i think
and this goes back to uh what i was
saying about disillusion
is um we had this enlightenment
uh where
some really brilliant ideas were
invented
some pretty bad ones were implemented as
well
um we had that you know uh
300 years ago began 300 years ago um
and then afterwards we'd entered into
this um
period afterwards where uh
certain other cultural forces have start
you know come into the picture started
to compete with
that enlightenment idea of progress of
human potential
of um the capacity for reason
to correct itself to um
to basically supply reasons to
everything uh
so you know uh remove the arbitrary the
unjust the irrational
from uh not just our picture of our work
the world but our conduct within it
um we've had this kind of
counter in the counter enlightenment was
actually a historical moment but i
think that we're still there's still um
it's still a prominent cultural strain
of these counter-enlightenment uh
you know it can be pessimistic and could
be romantic um
there are these cultural strains um
around that you know the the
the big philosophers like nietzsche uh
you know um uh some of the 20th century
philosophers as well like from sartre
uh down to dara they're all kind of
playing with these
anti-enlightenment ideas now
i don't want to make predictions about
uh culture because there are so many
degrees of freedom that you'd be an
idiot to do so
but i do feel that um
that that disillusion with
with enlightenment and its capacity
so not just what it was but what it
could be taking the good bits out of it
and critiquing the bad bits um you know
it's kind of growing up and this is what
the enlightenment you know the big dogs
in the enlightenment said themselves
kant said that it
is just uh you know um
humanity using its own reason to exit
its infancy
um this is where the metaphor comes from
actually where you see sagan
uh you know carl sagan said that we're
in this period of technological
adolescence
um defined by this miss you know this
misfit this disjunct between our
might and our wisdom um that's where the
metaphor comes from it actually comes
from uh
canton his his enlightenment forebears
so anyway what i'm saying is uh
you know we had this period of
enlightenment then we had the kind of uh
critique of it which is itself part of
the enlightenment is criticizing
uh you know critiquing um and
unveiling the biases unveiling the the
injustices
um and we're still kind of living
through this point i think it's
it is an offense to use sagan's term it
is a kind of adolescent phase where it's
like we've realized our capacities
we've realized the shared damage we can
do to ourselves and
this world that we live in uh and
lots of people react to that with this
this continuing disillusion of
this is awful humans are awful um
we can be right and it's
you know again these these metaphors can
become cheesy and they can become very
broad brush and very over generalized
but i think we are going through that
you know not just this technological
adolescence but also this kind of
adolescence in our image of ourselves
and what we can do within the world and
what uh
you know what we should do uh what we
ought to do
um yeah where you know there's a lot of
disillusion
um and taking this really broad broad
long-term
view of human history and culture and
ideas uh
that i like to do i see that as just a
necessary step in
you know waking up and growing up and
you know when you're a teenager there
are times when you
you know do something really awful and
you know uh
screw up then you feel really bad about
yourself
but then you learn that that's just part
of this process and so
yeah you know real broad brush long-term
uh talking i think that you know as
a civilization um and obviously you know
again that's a big abstraction
there are lots of parts and there are
lots of uh parts below that
but i think we're going through that
phase right now um
and yeah so i'm hopeful as to what to
come what's what's to come next uh
you know we've realized how bad we can
be uh
but now we can focus on stopping that
badness from
uh from you know um coming to the fore
and we can focus on what we can do uh
and our potential
we are gods but for the wisdom
who's that uh that is eric weinstein
actually all right and daniel
schmacktenberger said we're gods
we're just shitty gods uh which is
the same thing said in a different way
one thing that's just popped into my
head there mate
do you think that we're further ahead in
terms of ethics or technology
i mean they're kind of uh uh
uncomparable
i i i know that that's an apples and
oranges comparison but
if you were to think about personally to
me it seems like we're further ahead in
technology
it seems like our our technological
power outstrips our wisdom
we've made a lot of progress we made a
lot of progress with
ethics with understanding
what good is and how to act in the world
um but it seems like we're able to scale
technological progress much more quickly
than that
um yeah yeah yeah so caveat aside of you
know incomparability
um broadly yeah we are definitely ahead
in uh technological uh progress
um this is actually a this is actually a
point that perfect makes you know to
loop back to the beginning this is a
point that pathet makes
in this argument about how bad
extinction would be
um is he points out that applied ethics
so um you know
not just thinking about what value is
and arguing about meta ethics which is
you know what value is and
how we can define it but arguing how we
can actually implement our ideas of
value into the world so like you know
making ethics effective um is actually
really young um and so
as part of his wider argument that human
extinction would be so awful because we
have this
vast future ahead of us if we get things
right
um he says you know you can be uh
kind of aggregative about it and say
you know there will be so many zero zero
zero zero
uh future human uh lives but he says
there are also these
intrinsic goods these intrinsic values
um
uh so like art
science right knowing about the world uh
but any points this other one is
um ethics and he says this is the most
immature field of them all
uh is it's only since the enlightenment
that uh people have um
been doing secular ethics so thinking
about
morality without god breathing down the
back of your neck
um and it's only even more recently than
that
the people like pathet himself have
been dedicating uh their entire lives to
the pursuit of this
uh and trying to you know um
create you know get that low-hanging
fruit when it comes to uh
you know moral progress so that was the
words that i had in my head
the the low hanging fruit so i think um
i think uh yes we are in this stage
where our
you know our might kind of outstrips our
um our wisdom
uh we are in our technological
adolescence um or the precipice you know
however you want to describe it um
but that doesn't mean that there's you
know
again you know i think there's big
potential for
for moral progress and uh you know
people are working on these things like
applied ethics is booming there's this
effective altruist movement where people
are
you know thinking how best can we use
our resources uh there's uh
you know a kind of offshoot of that uh
more recently um
long-termism is this uh you know um idea
and i i
the precipice toby also precipice is
kind of the
the um i guess the founding uh
text of this but um and there's a lot
lots of work
uh coming out of the global priorities
institute which is kind of the sister
institute of the future of humanity
institute
on this long term ism yeah and it's
about you know how can we
how can we do applied ethics and uh
so yeah i i think you know our
technology is outstripping our wisdom
right now but um
there's there's there's low hanging
fruit to be picked there's some good
players about to run out under the pitch
for the applied ethics team as well
i hope so man i really do i think um i
think it's very timely for you to
to release a book about the the history
of existential risk
i really do um the press pissed by toby
ord
is a [ __ ] magnum opus i absolutely
adore that book
um super intelligence fantastic uh
uh what is it human compatible by stuart
russell which came out last year that's
also fantastic but this thomas moynin
x-risk how humanity discovered its own
extinction
dude you've done a really really good
job with this the number of footnotes
is absolutely terrifying um
it's it's completely ridiculous
and uh for anybody that's enjoyed this
conversation today it will be linked in
the show notes below i've also added
this
to my amazon reading list because that's
how much i enjoyed it so
go and check this out if you want uh
anywhere else that you want to send
people
um my website is thomas moynihan or xyz
i keep that updated with uh like short
essays that i do
um so yeah i think that's it perfect man
the
end of civilization hasn't occurred
during this podcast so we have managed
to make it through
thank you for coming on cheers thanks a
lot for having me
you